this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status symbol of choice
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
number one best-selling author and
best-selling author many times over
we're here to answer your questions
about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five but that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five and you are here also
to announce
uh a new um offering today
a new thing you did a new thing yes a
new thingy
so thanks for having me on sure um and
yeah
i came out with my new wallets uh a few
months ago
and the colors were black and camel
anyone wondering
but i was like i want to design a fun
wall that you can use the cache envelope
system but yet
as a woman it's cute and you get to
carry it so uh
we did a special it's a limited edition
so we only
we only ordered a pretty small amount
honestly so you'll have to get it
soon because it probably will sell out
in the next day or two um
for mother's day but a blush metallic a
metallic blush
sounds like a punk rock band which is
metallic
look at it on camera i mean it's just
the most beautiful thing ever
it's it's my favorite i mean it's i was
like okay i need i have every color but
i was like no this is i want to use this
but what's also great about these
wallets is we partnered with join
which is an incredible organization they
make authentic leather goods
and they're incredible they take people
in parts of india um
that need a job to literally feed their
family and get off the street and get
off the street and get out of
you know other sectors of life that are
just terrible and so they give them
these women and men jobs to to create
this so
um they're the ones that actually make
it and and so it's amazing so it comes
from india and then every wallet comes
with a card of the person that made it
so it's handmade authentic leather
uh and it's just beautiful there's ten
card slots in here so for gift cards
like qvc or something oh man
this is correct no but then it has like
the envelope systems there and in it
yeah and you know a pocket for change
zipper
gold accents it's just beautiful so we
did it for mother's day so
if you need a gift for your mom you can
get
the new wallet metallic blush i'm
telling you that's a great name well we
did
thank you i didn't name the color but
that's the name of the color
but i we you know we pulled my tribe and
people that i've bought the wallet okay
if you want another color because that's
what it keeps saying
another color and it was like pink light
pink blush pink pink pink pink pink we
want pink we want pink
and so the metallic pink is there it is
it's beautiful
yes yes yes yes so again you go to
ramsay solutions.com
to order it we have a limited uh
quantity and then it's going to be gone
forever but it's funny so it does it has
the whole envelope system
built in 10 debit card slots built in
coin pouch
wristlet the whole thing and uh our
product guys have worked
very very hard on the development of
this thing for the other two colors to
start with and then
adding this color to it and um you know
uh
the truth is i had absolutely nothing to
do with any of this rachel had a little
bit to do with the design
speaking into it and speak you know so
it would do what she wanted it to do but
um so ramsay solutions.com
and just check out uh products or go to
the store slash store
and you can get the new metallic blush
wallet and in the inside the envelopes
it's like this mauve color in there
okay with the plaid oh yeah it's
important this is very pretty
all the ladies will appreciate it all
the ladies will appreciate it
i have no idea i would imagine you're
right but yeah
yeah so check it out dave
ramseysolutions.com
store the metallic brush blush uh rachel
criswell and we really
you know you guys know out there the
supply chains are all screwed up
shipping lanes are all screwed up
getting stuff here from another country
and getting stuff here from north
carolina is dad gum near impossible
these days so uh you know we really did
end up with a limited quantity because
of
everything so screwed up and so it it
that's not right and we did it because
we didn't and i mean yeah the logistics
of it but also it's a color that's not
gonna just be
consistent like throughout the years we
decided let's just do a fun new color
but then you're gonna not gonna like it
anymore no not the blush no oh
yeah it's done after this after this oh
so it's like beanie babies you're gonna
run it
it's like you're going to run out the
princess diana i'm kidding we went to
all this trouble just for a few hundred
few thousand two thousand two thousand
two thousand two thousand oh my god
but it but but it's already telling like
yesterday
they sent a text out to people that
signed up for the early one yeah i mean
it's still no it's not gone but it's not
gone but it's gonna go
i keep getting updated numbers and it's
fun it's great hopefully people can
handle their money better you know there
we go with a metallic blush wallet
open phones this hour as we talk about
your life and your money and your
metallic blush wallets
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five
i cannot believe we're doing this and
they're gonna run out
and never get more after you've made a
hot product that just runs against my
whole
way of marketing things you should
always sell until nobody wants to buy
we have the camel in the black color i
know i know
i just didn't know we were doing that i
learned something new every day
live here come to the meetings so that's
true probably
probably wasn't invited but there you go
so uh
all right open phones again at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five you jump in we'll we
will talk about your life and your money
the other thing you can do with with uh
is you can check out rachel cruz's show
it is uh of course on facebook and
youtube
uh live and uh the podcast is huge
uh tons of people attending that and be
sure to check that out
um at rachelcrews.com or
ramseysolutions.com and you can find any
of our
personalities anything they are doing
and plug into the
the podcast and the youtube live streams
and the whole bit so
the 14 day money finder is out there uh
as well sign up for this two week
challenge
on rachelcrews.com the average person is
finding an extra two thousand dollars
with these 14
day money finder which means they get
something new every day to look for
money
that's right yes when i created this i
wanted quick
tips because i just know how crazy my
life is so i was like if i'm going to do
something i kind of need a
something that can be quick so you can
do it you know under 15 minutes or less
most of these
and so it's everything from as easy as
signing into your checking account
online which some people don't even know
their password to it because they don't
do it
two things like insurance rates all of
it but yeah it's it's been a great i've
had it for a few years now and and
people
i mean it works because again it's
helping you get intentional
with your money and you get an email
once a day with an idea exactly to save
money 100
yeah find money okay all right so and
you sign up for that at rachelcruze.com
as well so be sure and check that out
again the number here to join us is
triple eight
eight two five five two two five now
guys i wanted to stop a second
sidestep rachel this time last year most
people were at home
yeah yes quarantining uh
or sheltering or whatever word we used
for
being trapped in your house and um
a lot of people were very afraid
about their money a lot of lost jobs
they were worried about if they were
going to lose their job they were
worried about the debt that they have
they were worried about their emergency
fund
and a lot of people said you know what
i'm not i'm never going to be here again
and then some of you had that feeling
but you never did anything about it and
now you're kind of just back to normal
doing stupid butt stuff again
that was your wake-up call to do
the ramsey stuff to do the baby steps to
get the total money makeover book to get
in ramsey plus
for god's sakes to get your blush wallet
whatever it takes for you to change your
life and never be back in that situation
again
you need to have a never again moment
from covid
where you say never again is my family
going to be vulnerable
financially because i didn't do the
stuff to get out of debt and build the
emergency fund
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five rachel cruz ramsey
personality is my co-host today
ashley's in west palm beach california
hi ashley how are you west palm beach
david florida florida i would think yeah
i saw that on the screen and read it
like i was anchorman or something okay
so i knew better as i was reading it how
can we help
uh well um i am currently in baby step
two and i have a
about ten thousand dollars left on a
student loan however it's currently in
part of the class action lawsuit so i'm
not required to make any payments on it
um so i've been using what i would have
paid on that towards the rest of my
snowball
it's not currently accruing any interest
anything like that
i'm just not sure if i should pay it off
what is the
what's the nature of the class action
lawsuit
uh it was for false advertising for job
placement rates
um and things like that so it was for
like a technical school
technical school still open no that
they're closed
they went broke shut down well your
student your student loan is
your student loan is supposed to be
forgiven under federal guidelines
in that situation anyway well i was
i had already graduated from the school
doesn't matter that happened so i wasn't
currently
really yeah doesn't matter if the school
closed due to
if the school went bankrupt it's an
indication that they were running a scam
and the fed one of the federal it's one
of the few types of student loan
forgiveness that actually does occur
you can you actually get a high rate of
these that are forgiven
so you need to get in touch with the
feds and work that through you said it's
a ten thousand dollar balance and it's
your only debt left
uh it's why i have two left i have about
eight thousand left on a credit card but
i've been using the student loan
payments
to pay down the credit card faster since
i've not been required to pay payments
on the student loan yeah
okay well yeah what i do is knock the
credit card out and then i would save up
ten thousand dollars
extra above your normal emergency fund
of three to six months
so that if this all falls apart you can
write a check and be out of debt
that's what i thought you'd say but i
just i needed to hear it from you yeah
but in the meantime you need to
investigate the federal
uh you know get on the websites with the
feds because i think you're going to get
this whole thing forgiven anyway
regardless of the class action
okay now do you think they would forgive
and reimburse forever anything that i've
paid
that's my concern no it's just afraid no
the fed the feds don't guarantee
that schools don't go broke but they do
forgive
federally insured student loans on
schools that close
okay regardless of your career if you're
a current student or not
yes yeah okay double check it jump in on
the student loan websites
and uh uh james that site that you sent
me the other day that had the different
types on it do you remember what it was
off the top of your head
that'll touch my head but i can find it
insanity okay yeah well
she'll be going by then but anyway yeah
it's so but there there's a site we were
just looking at the other day
and uh you know there's two or three
types of student loan forgiveness that
actually do occur that's all yeah that's
what i was about to say because usually
it's one of those impossible things that
it's a dream that people have that's
going to happen and it usually doesn't
it's called that but the pslf is the one
that sucks that everybody thinks is
going to happen and nobody gets that
doesn't doesn't really occur
and so the public stu public service
student loan forgiveness after 10 years
and that's what
so many people are betting the farm on
and they're getting screwed
and the current numbers like we just
pulled this up the other day off this
site that
we were talking about here um the uh
227 000 people have applied for that
and only 3 000 have gotten it so it's
less it's about one percent
now the type that she has or a closed
school discharge it would be 100 or a
discharge due to death
or a discharge due to disability or
there's an another one for teachers
and sometimes nurses that do the inner
city the or the rural
underserved areas they're called that's
a five-year plan and those students
there's a high rate of the forgiveness
on those but the public service student
loan forgiveness one is the ones that
joke yep so it's educationdata.org
say it again educationdata.org so if
you're still there
uh it's educationdata.org
educationdata.org or data.org
and um yeah that's where you can start
to find out this
this deal but the the if you went to and
a lot of them were
very few very few times just like a
four-year university club
right but there were a lot of these uh
vo-tech things a truck driving school
a computer programming school or
whatever and
you go in there and they run the student
that basically they're running a scam to
you know get people signed student loans
they cash in all the money they take off
and the school closes
how does that happen often enough that
they decided to put it in the dead
that's true
yeah too often yeah yeah it's not say
everybody in that space is slimy but
there was enough slime in that space
that the
discharge due to school closing is a
thing yeah
that's a thing and you don't have to do
it through a class action
so jump in there and learn about it and
you can get the details
and get moving on it sam is in atlanta
hi sam
welcome to the ramsey show hey thanks
dave
what's up hey rachel hey dave uh thanks
for tuning in call this afternoon
um kinda i had a quick question so
uh my wife and i uh we're in i guess
starting out baby step
uh maybe step six now so we've
paid off any debts we had and got three
six months of expenses
and um are able to invest 15 of our
income
we are set to receive about 180
000 in a inheritance in the form of a
mutual fund
and our current mortgage is about 140
000. and i was just curious what
will maybe be the most a smart
thing to do with that inheritance would
it be to pay off the mortgage
uh immediately with it or keep it
invested and
continue for that to grow in the mutual
fund and that's just continue to
attack the mortgage sam yeah you guys
are
the no income yeah well you're in a
great position right now
because you are literally going to get
be able to cash out
mutual funds and have enough to pay off
your mortgage with
40 000 left over so if i woke up in your
shoes
and that was given to me i would pay off
the house that day
and be on my way to baby step 7
and continue on sam it's interesting
that you
said you know we're going to walk the
baby steps until you got a lump sum and
then you questioned it
yeah yep isn't that weird i mean that's
kind of weird if you think about it
but that's what it does it made you
question the whole the whole theory
because
if if the other way if not paying it off
and you and
use it to invest then we would have put
that in the baby steps right we would
have said never pay off your house
always keep your money invested
right and what we found though is is
that all the millionaires that we've
studied and all the
tens of thousands of people we've walked
with over all these 30 years
that have built wealth none of them
said when interviewed oh i got rich
because i kept
i always borrowed all i could on my
house and kept the money invested in
mutual funds
none of them said that none not one
you know instead i hear all the time we
paid off our house and that was the
biggest breakthrough because when the
house was paid off man we took all those
house payments
we started investing those and we ended
up with a million dollars so fast it was
blinding
and uh i and a paid for house in the mix
and so you end up you know with a net
worth of one to two million dollars
fairly quickly
yeah and it's a good question sam
because i do i understand how you got
there because you're thinking okay
suddenly math starts to come into play
and you're thinking okay can i kind of
outsmart this and invest that because
i'm going to make more off the interest
versus what you know i mean yeah
you started but if you were going to pay
it off gradually it would never would
have come up right
right but the fact that there's
something weird the way our brains
trigger yes
we'll have to ask deloney how that works
because i don't there's something about
the way
our brains you know our brains well and
and i would say sam too
i i mean i would feel this way right
you're working hard you guys are on baby
step
six yeah you've done a great job you
sound like a fairly young
man you know you're not you know from
just the tone of your voice
so i'm like there's almost this emotion
you have to catch up to
for being handed 180 000 dollars like
you know you because you hardly don't
feel worthy i almost wish yeah
you know i wish i could hear more of his
story because i'm like i bet they worked
hard to
you know you're just used to just
cranking it out and
and then you're given it it almost feels
too good to be true or something it's
like whoa it can't be this easy
did i do something wrong or something
like it can't be this easy and
and it's like your emotions haven't
caught up to the reality of what's
happening
financially for you guys and what a
blessing i mean what a gift and whoever
left you that in the inheritance what a
way to pass on their legacy
to do something like this with this
money i think it's just tremendous sam
it's awesome pay off your house dude use
the house payment to become wealthy
change your family tree i'm so proud for
you you've done really good you've done
a great job
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for joining us america rachel
cruz ramsey personality my daughter
number one best-selling author many
times over is my co-host today
taking your questions about your life
and about your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five nico is with us from
estonia hi
nico how are you oh hello thank you how
are you sir
better than i deserve what part of
estonia are you in
part two it's a very small city although
the second biggest city in estonia
rachel and i and our family visited
talon a few years ago or t
it's talon is that how you pronounce it
yes yeah
beautiful beautiful city how can we help
i saw estonia and i said
not many people can probably say i have
been to your country
how can we help you sir me and my fiance
are moving to us to indiana notre dame
for our phd degrees
both in the same department we are
debt-free we do not have any debt we
have or our moving
costs covered and we both have
fellowship
the thing is we will have some salary
left over every month
and we have no idea about american
economics or how can we invest or what
we should do with it
should we go ahead let's let me say that
we'll have about 2 000
left each month on the side after eating
providing for shelter from everything
that and
what should we do should we plan to buy
a house maybe next year
or should we invest in a different way i
would love to listen to your advice
wow what do you what's your phd you're
studying
bioengineering i am building synthetic
hearts
wow wow so will you be when you finish
the phd will you be returning or will
you be staying
in the us i haven't made up my mind yet
but i think i will stay a little bit
longer too
for postdoc okay
well south bend is a beautiful town been
there a lot of times notre dame's a
fabulous campus so you you've signed up
for the
a world-class ride there the um
if you're going to be there five years
or
longer buying a home is not a bad idea
if you're not going to be there five
years or longer it's questionable
all right i was thinking the money i'm
going to pay for rent which is about
1200 a month
i can just pay it for mortgage and even
if i don't stay
there at the end i can sell the house
and
get some of those money back instead of
well
you won't necessarily unless you stay
five years we don't know if the
typically the house will not go up
enough in value
and you've got to make sure you can get
the house sold houses you know right now
houses are selling like crazy the real
estate market's quite hot
but a few years ago you couldn't give
one away so um
you know you don't want to get into a
home if you're not going to be there
five years because your trade out for
rent is not one for one
because you can turn around and lose
money on the house and make you wish you
had rented
uh if you're not gonna if you're only
gonna be there in the house two or three
years or something
and the south bend market's a solid
market
there's nothing wrong with it i you know
it's not a bad place to own real estate
but all real estate needs to be
purchased with a five year window or
longer
other than that i would just pile up the
cash because nico a pile of cash
just gives you lots of options and then
as you decide where you're gonna stay
and where you're gonna be that pile of
cash can be applied wherever you are
and that that's true in any economy yeah
absolutely would you
would you recommend him investing if
he's not gonna be here five years or
longer
yeah if you're gonna be if you want to
play if you want to do like an index
fund and park some of that money that's
fine
uh but uh the big thing the money's
gonna give you that's gonna be more than
anything else is just the flexibility
which uh to move to another city if
you're going to stay in the u.s to move
back to estonia if you're going back
you know apollo cash just gives you
options and sometimes those options are
more valuable than what you might have
made on an investment yeah it's good
and so uh certainly real estate will be
a mistake if you're only going to be
there a couple years
um most of the time i mean there's a few
times you get out hold but i just i love
real estate but it's not a short term
play
and it's not a play it's not a trade-off
for rent everybody's got this thing
about you know
versus rent it it really doesn't work
out that way except in the long haul
short range it does not work out that
way jordan's in portland oregon hi
jordan welcome to the ramsey show what's
up
hey dave rachel thank you both for
taking the time to talk to me today sure
uh so long story short my wife and i
we just got married in august of last
year i've been
living out here for the past three years
uh
hometown is originally colorado where i
own a rental property
the rental property right now is under
contract to be sold for 6.85
original listing price is 501 so all
things considered i think is a great
return on investment
good night but um yeah real estate in
denver's been blowing up recently so
uh what would is my wife and i we both
have
some debt right now outside of the
mortgage
it's truck payments and credit card debt
and some school
and uh what we want to do is just move
them forward from here we want to make
be good stewards of our finances and
make sure we're doing what's right
and doing the best with these proceeds
from the sale so i was looking for some
guidance from you both today see what
any suggestions you might have in mind
so how much cash will you get
out of the home from what you owe what
you made i mean obviously you guys made
a ton on it
right right and after what i calculated
after
closing costs yeah commissions and all
that and taxes
i think we'll be walked stepping away at
about 225 okay
and then uh how much debt do you guys
have i know you said you have truck
credit card all of that how much is all
that
that was a boneheaded move after
listening to to dave recently
uh i i kind of got over my head and
bought the truck and was not a whole lot
down i've still got about 40 000 left on
the truck
uh 15. what does all of that what is all
that total too including the truck
uh see bear with me
63 000 okay all right
awesome well so um yeah jordan i mean
when you get that 225 yeah you can write
a check for
63 000 be completely out of debt put a
chunk of it away
and for an emergency fund so you and
your wife sit down and figure out okay
how much is
our expenses per month and multiply that
by three four five or six
you have three to six months worth of
expenses saved for that emergency fund
and then from there i mean and you
you're gonna be able to do a lot of this
in
like one day when you get the check from
that house which is so fun
uh and you're gonna be yeah i mean and
then yeah start investing some of it
into retirement do you guys own a home
right now did you say in portland
no we're uh we're renting right now
complex do you guys want to buy
a home that's what we like yeah that's
our dream one of these days
yeah that's awesome well after that
emergency fund i mean you could take
some of that for a down payment if you
guys
i would use the rest of it for the down
payment yeah throw it over
debt-free with an emergency fund and
whatever's left is your down payment
so if i remember you're saying three to
six months in an emergency fund
and going off of what our monthly
expenses look like right now
that's about 24 000
and then you're gonna have 130 000 bucks
to put down on the house
right i mean that's that's all that gets
a lot of house
and i don't i mean that that's the
decision i think
i've i've been we've been going back and
forth on is
do we want to use all of it for the down
payment on the house or would it make
sense to only maybe use a chunk of it
and invest the rest or
you know you know well again our
experience from the last 30 years
working with people who become
millionaires is they get their house
paid off
yeah and the first step to getting your
house paid off is a big hairy down
payment not investing the money
we just do not meet very many wealthy
people in the millionaire
range the one to five million dollar net
worth the first time people become
millionaires
that did it by keeping their house
leveraged and investing the money
almost all of them say we got the house
paid off as quickly as we could
and we started investing 15 percent of
our household income into retirement
and then when the house got paid off we
started investing even more and
they end up with a million to a million
and a half in in their 401ks and then
their retirement plans
and a paid four five six seven hundred
thousand dollar house and that's how
they end up with their million dollar
net worth and it
it's a very stable way of doing it it's
the baby steps that we teach from the
total money makeover book
and i would say jordan look to see the
size of house you guys want you may
you may be thinking that's a huge down
payment that's a that's a lot of house
well then don't get that much house
and then that down payment will take
maybe 50 of the mortgage
and then from there once all that cash
is gone start investing go back to your
baby steps four five and six so the pass
won't be completely paid off you'll be
investing before that
absolutely i'll send you a copy of the
book the total money makeover that has
the baby steps on steroids and it shows
you every detail
and if you'll follow that you'll be
wealthy you'll be a baby steps
millionaire
what's going to happen awesome jordan
great job
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ramsey personality rachel cruz number
one best-selling author
my daughter is my co-host today here on
the ramsey show
open phones at 825-522
our question today comes from blinds.com
they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code ramsay
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from
sandra in virginia i just completed baby
step two
and am able to cash flow college tuition
for my two
teenage children this has drastically
slowed down my ability to save
for a fully funded emergency fund both
kids work
and apply for scholarships should my
priority be to pay their tuition for
three more years
or build my emergency fund uh
sandra b to build your emergency fund so
your kids they're working
scholarships all that's amazing and that
should all be applied to their college
but hopefully they're going to a school
they can afford
while they're doing all of that and so
it sounds
you know i know as a parent it feels
like okay i'm being a bad parent because
i'm putting myself first i should be
able to help them because i have the
ability to
but you have to be able to help yourself
first you need this solid
financial foundation under you to make
sure that if anything happens
in your life you have the cash to cover
it and so that emergency fund is
is crucial and then saving for
retirement next and then i'll be putting
15
of my income into retirement and then
after that's completed as you're doing
that
then you can help with kids college so
um again parents
it goes against their natural
um way of thinking with parenting of no
no i'm supposed to help my kids and
and i do want you to help your kids but
you're not a bad parent if you don't
help your kid with
college so taking care of you first and
foremost financially is the priority
yeah and um
when the oxygen masks drop they don't
say put your oxygen mesh on your kid
first
they said put the oxygen mask on
yourself first
then you are able because you can
breathe
and you haven't passed out to take care
of your children
and so retirement unless you die
is going to occur emergencies
are going to occur period college
may or may not occur now they're in
school so it is occurring
but you know we just have to find a way
to do this we have to find a way to push
it through
pull this off and and you guys are going
to scratch around
i think they need to have applied for
more scholarships i think they applied
for three
and they quit and they need to do 300.
yeah
and i think they work but i don't think
they work enough
i worked 40 to 60 hours a week when i
was in school
most people work while they're in
college
most people in america work while
they're in college it's highly unusual
for someone to not work while they're in
school i mean i don't know where we got
this idea that people don't have to work
while they're good now these kids are
working they're working
they're working well choice too i'm just
saying
what are you doing for money are you
making stinking minimum wage or you're
doing something that's actually
profitable yep
because you know flopping whoppers is
tough to pay tuition with
right at minimum wage it's just really
hard to do so you need to do something
where you actually make some money
whether it's an entrepreneurial endeavor
or whether it's hard work that other
people don't want to do like
cutting grass delivering pizzas you know
you can make a lot more money doing some
things than you can doing other things
when you for college work
absolutely and so we need to address
that we need to address the scholarships
and how many
we need to address where they're going
to school is it affordable
and if you address all of those things i
think you guys can pull this off
but it is not healthy to um
go with the natural instinct of i'll
take care of my children first which you
should i mean you should
you know in you know we most of us would
say we would jump in front of a bullet
for our kids most of us would say we
would dive in front of a car and push
them out of the way for our kids
all of that is true but that's a life or
death situation
uh you know we would feed our children
before we fed ourselves
that's a life or death situation this is
financial
yeah and uh and so it's it goes against
your natural instinct but it's also the
right way the wise way to do it
i am suggesting you help with college
but only after the emergency fund's in
place and 15
is going into retirement as rachel said
so guys
what we figured out a few years ago is
there's 73
000 things coming at you that wants your
money
and then when you get some money because
you went to work
or because you get a lump sum or because
you sold your rental property or
whatever it is you get some money
you go i don't know which of these 73
000 do i do
how do i do this and people become
overwhelmed and they do nothing
and then they end up doing something
stupid with the money instead of
actually being intentional and having a
plan
so 20 some odd years ago almost 30 years
ago
coaching families we determined
that you needed a very specific clear
path
and we developed that over many years
in actual practice it was not
theoretical
meaning tens of thousands of families
that we walked with to develop
these highly tuned baby steps
and baby step one comes
before baby step two
it's not an accident that two is after
one
and that three is after two and that
five is after four
and that six is after five and that four
is before five these are not accidents
this is a highly developed
highly uh processed
series of concepts that are have proven
to
tens of millions of families in america
now
to be the shortest distance between
where you are in wealth
now you can go make up your own freaking
plan but your plan got you where you are
and so you need to decide you know you
don't need to call rachel
and anthony and christy and deloney and
me
and coleman and ask us if baby step
three
should be after baby step two it is
that's why we called it three
and you don't need to change it it you
know it's a pretty
and it doesn't really change there's
it is the shortest method to get there
shut up and do it okay tell me this do
you feel like
you've heard more of this happening in
the last
five years the last hour
the last few years versus over the last
20 because i feel like more than ever
today the culture
it's a it's it's a little bit infested
with
yeah but this is my snowflake i'm a
snowflake i'm unique
you're unique but the law of gravity
applies to all snowflakes i know but i'm
just saying
it did you see it culturally like do you
think that that like do you
have do you see this resistance or have
you always seen it no it's always it's
always been
it's a natural because it's your unique
i mean people say yes
because what happens is the very
confusion of the 73 000 things you can
do with money
yeah yeah you have to bring it back to
the table continually
until you actually believe that there is
logic and data
and decades and tens of millions of
lives
that have done it the right way and
gotten the positive result
until you submit yourself to the plan
you know it's like hiring a personal
trainer and he says well you probably
need to eat less yeah but i'm not going
to do that i just want to do the workout
you know well no you got to eat less fat
boy
you know that's what i'm looking in the
mirror i got a keg he's got a six-pack
why am i arguing with the six-pack boy
about nutrition
when i'm fat why am i arguing with him
he told me what to do
he i hired him i paid him to tell me
what to do
and then i've got a better plan and then
i look at my belly and go well how's
that a better plan
you know this is what ought to go
through people's head yeah
it's true it's true or the trainer says
do more lunges i'm like
i don't want to do those i'm not doing
it i don't like leg days
i don't like leg day i don't think i
want to do that
yeah i think i'm just going to pick out
i'm going to do my version of your
plan that works because my version has
got me where i am it's the dumbest thing
ever well it's not the dumbest thing
ever it's because
i know why because it feels good in the
moment to do what you feel like is safe
to do and stepping outside of what you
feel like is safe and doing a plan that
makes you uncomfortable because you're
having to change
that's why you know oh yeah it's comfort
zone crap yeah it is
exactly what it is but you have to
decide you know you have to decide did
your comfort zone
get you to where you are yes do you like
where you are
no then get out of your comfort zone you
look great though i've lost 37 pounds
because i looked in the mirror and i
went
fat boy you gotta do something about
that that's
shape talk i did i did look at my
shoulders
alone it caused me to it caused me to
lose weight though i mean you just you
know
your self-awareness is part of the
process right
oh my gosh this is the ramsey show
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for
joining us rachel cruz ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author
multiple times is my co-host today we're
here to answer your questions about your
life and your money open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five travis
is in boston
to start off this hour hi travis how are
you
hi dave i'm good how you doing better
than i deserve how can we help
well thank you for having me uh i
discovered you about
two and a half years ago right before
becoming a father
and you have completely changed my life
and how i handle economics
and the reason for my call today is
because uh we currently live in a house
and we have about forty five thousand
dollars left in this mortgage
uh no other debt uh but we're
entertaining the idea of buying a much
bigger house with an in-law apartment
with a that would allow mining laws
to move and stay with us for 650 000
which would obviously restart my
mortgage clock and
the idea of being uh debt free before
the age of 35 sounds very appealing
but i also think that new big house
would improve our quality of life and
actually make us happy
as well and if you will approve of the
new house
would you recommend selling or renting
my current house
okay well i would always sell your house
currently because you don't have the
money to pay cash for the new one
and so the only way we buy rentals is
with cash and uh so
we wouldn't keep that property unless
you were able to pay cash for your home
because in effect you've borrowed money
for the rental otherwise so no we're
going to sell it for sure what's the
home you're living in worth
uh about 425 000
okay all right and so we're
talking about only a 250 000
mortgage right if i sell this house yes
yes well that that's no longer in
question if you're going to
do what we tell you to do so i would
tell you to sell the house so
and then you're going to put it on as
short a term as you can 15 years or less
what's your household income
uh 160 thousand dollars a hundred and
what
160 160 okay good
how old are you uh 32 sir you've done
very well ron
good job man i'm sorry travis very well
done
very well done thank you i've been
listening to you non-stop
we've been maxing out 401ks maxing out
rough iras and uh
so we have a second baby coming in
september so we're getting ready for it
thank you awesome congratulations
so your in-laws are how old uh my laws
are in their 60s and they currently live
in greece where both my wife and
i my wife and i are from
okay they would move here no income they
would pretty much be staying with us
and be babysitters in a sense
[Music]
well i'm not a big fan in general of
mother-in-law and father-in-law
apartments
because it ends up with a weird house
later uh
when all of this doesn't work out but
this is a very unusual situation a
you've got the cultural
differences between uh greece and the
u.s
to where it would be more normal to have
all the family in one house in the us we
tend to be more
individualistic um and that's just a
cultural difference neither is right or
wrong
it's just a different way of looking at
things and doing things uh
then the the but i you know i looked at
a house the other day had a
mother-in-law
apartment in it that was a dadgum house
you know
attached to the other house and it was
just like it made a weird house is what
it did
and you know and we don't we weren't
moving anybody in with us so we don't
want that you know so
it just made a it made you have a hard
property to sell later
um so your configuration of the house
needs to be fairly normal
uh and it can't be some bizarre
mother-in-law apartment thing off the
side because you're gonna make it very
limited market when you get ready to
sell it someday
it is exactly what you're describing
actually it is very bizarre we actually
know the current owners we've known them
for a very long time and the in-law
apartment is 1900 square feet it's
massive
wow okay it's bigger than our current
house the in-law part of the in-law
aspect is bigger than the actual house
we live in right now and the main thing
is about 3 000 square feet yeah i think
you're gonna have trouble selling that
house later
very likely very likely but if you're in
it for 10 15 years
do you matter i mean you know if you if
it's not if it's a weird house when you
move in guess what when you move out
it's still going to be a weird house
yeah but it is weirdness worth it though
for your quality of life considering
yeah you have parents coming immigrating
in and i i think i
i i you know in your situation i i
don't want to make a case for them not
to move in with you i think moving in
with you
and moving to a bigger house is probably
better idea i'm not sure the one you're
looking at is the one
because i'm going to do this in a more
uh in a way that the house can be
utilized more
in a more traditional way when you leave
and that'll give you a much broader
market the house will do better you have
a higher likelihood of getting it sold
you're not gonna get stuck with this
white elephant which is what these
things are when you build these bizarre
properties and so uh you can do it if
you want to do it but the downside is
you're gonna have trouble getting out of
it later
but i would say travis to your original
question though sell the current house
you're in that's okay you don't wait
until it's paid
that's all okay uh but the house itself
the actual
you know the actual house uh you know be
careful with that part of it
because that's where you can get burned
in this whole thing because
um i mean there's going to be a day when
you blink twice
and mom and dad are in heaven and you've
got this house with this empty wing
you know and it just goes fast unless
life goes fast and and so
that's what happens and then um you know
you end up
these people that were selling this
property we were looking at that's what
happened to them
and you know the house is eight years
old and they
built it specifically for her mother and
you know and and it's useless
it's useless because it's just so
bizarre for any for
a traditional family using it right
without a mother-in-law i mean so i'm
thinking about what am i going to put
over there in that in that thing
often you know it just it made me not
want to do the deal
so um uh and that was three weeks ago so
but anyway
you know so you can you can you can
decide but that that's uh
i i think the ideas that you're playing
with all work
but just be careful with where you put
the final product uh in terms of
you don't want to get stuck with
something later but uh you got a great
heart
and obviously you've done a great job
say awesome travis i mean you're not
even you're 33 somebody said yeah
killing it so just killing so very well
done
so very well done yeah and
here's the thing too the the to the rest
of you you know you think about
uh uh latino countries you know uh
often you know families all in one house
that's not unusual
but again anglos very seldom mm-hmm
very seldom uh we'll do just i mean we
buy the house next door for mom
right but we don't put them in our house
as often not as often as other cultures
do
yeah and so that's where this thing
called personal finance comes into play
it is personal
because this is a family with a a
grecian heritage
and so that plays into the decision
making and
and it should yeah absolutely absolutely
that's a good thing
so uh we want to honor that want you to
honor that your heritage and your
your cultural upbringing and tendencies
and all those kinds of things
but just in the midst of it be wise
that's the whole thing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five if you've been paying
attention the real estate market you
know it's out of control it's crazy
competition to buy a property
multiple offers it's crazy inventory has
been hitting all-time lows
now when inventory is low it simply
means there's more buyers buying than
sellers selling
which turns the pressure up buyers want
to snag the right house sellers want to
accept the right offer
this is not amateur hour
to win in this market you need a pro by
your side and that's why we find
veterans and endorse top real estate
agents and we really go through and vet
them we look at what they're doing
all across the country we call them our
endorsed local providers these are high
octane high protein real estate agents
and you need someone like that in your
corner to play in this market
if you're going to sell i mean it's a
process right now
you're going to buy it's a process right
now
and our agents have years of industry
success and they refuse to compromise
your financial goals no matter what is
going on out there
so you can instantly connect with an
endorsed local provider in your area
text
house 233 789 text
house to 33789
to find a ramsey trusted agent near
you can we talk real estate for a second
yeah let's do so
we're talking during the break about
just even in nashville it's just
it's crazy right now like our friends
are trying to buy houses and they're
asking like insane
over asking price and they're still not
getting it like it's just wild so
kovit plays into this and i know real
estate you know you look over
decades and decades you see the influx
of things going up and down i mean it's
just like
anything else but what do you i mean it
just feels like it's insane right now
and i
don't know if that's just because we
live in nashville and nationals it's
everywhere so
so what does covid cause people because
i would think coming out of 2020 you
almost are more conservative and you're
holding tight and you're
staying put because it still feels a
little unstable right like we're not
even i feel like out of
all the stuff with covid so why
why the like why the surge well several
things but
the baseline on it is there's a shortage
on new housing
because the lumber factory shut down
and a lot of the other components of the
house the factories shut down yeah a new
lumber system
get lumber yeah and then when you can't
get it it drove the prices way up on
that yeah
and uh then there starts to be a frenzy
around it
a feeding frenzy like piranhas you know
it's like crazy
and uh and and so the new housing
slowed to nothing and there's this gap
of six or eight months of production
of the components therefore the new
houses
and when you take the new housing gap uh
supply out the inventory supply out then
it shortens up the
well i can't get a new house so i gotta
go buy a used house and so it doubles
doubles down
plus many people looking at half the
numbers of houses and so you end up with
a
inventory shortage of new and used
housing
and a shortage always cause i mean you
got you know half the number
of houses for sale as there are buyers
out there you know two to one three to
one ratio whatever four to one whatever
the ratio is
then you know that just that alone did
this but the coke
what kovit did was it shut down not the
real estate market because people are
still buying houses during
quarantine they were buying them sight
unseen on zoom and other stuff right
right
but but the uh uh the factory shutting
down
the supply chain getting screwed up has
screwed up the economy
so it's and then the buyers go crazy
yeah and then the sellers go crazy yeah
and then the buyers go crazier
and so there's this this cycle of just
this feeding
frenzy and it's all in motion and and so
you know you're seeing properties uh in
lots of towns get multiple multiple
offers
uh you know fifty a hundred thousand
dollars over asking prices yeah
and they line up through the whole
weekend and there's 62 offers on a house
over the weekend that's not unusual in a
lot of cities right now
but that'll subside it'll just
eventually the feeding frenzy calms down
and then they'll just be this like
hangover uh you know
like the housing hangover after that
it'll just be like
like the morning you felt this ever i
mean for four years i've never seen it
like this exactly yeah but uh in 19
in the 19 uh what we are going to see
out of this that you've never seen your
generation has ever seen is inflation
inflation the components that make up
the inflation index
housing is one of them it's the biggest
part of inflation
and when housing shoots up and oil
shoots up
and oil has shot up too yeah it has yeah
and uh you know
you look at the gas pump oh i know i
filled up my minivan two days ago
nobody's talking nobody's talking about
it but the gas pump doubles and housing
goes up a bunch
then all of a sudden you're gonna see
stuff like i saw in the 70s and 80s
which was double digit inflation where
stuff's going up 10 15 a year
and inflation was out of control and the
politicians it took
it you know it took some real strong
politicians to do away with it uh it was
out of control how do they do away with
it
well i i credit ronald reagan i'm just
putting the brakes on because it was out
of control under carter and he comes in
and
shifted economic policy and uh just
started
opening up uh doing away with regulation
opening up the markets
because if you can flood the market with
supply
it slows down as flows down the feeding
frenzy because if you can get it
everywhere there's no scarcity
sure then the prices start to settle
you know if there's an oversupply prices
go down if there's an under supply
prices go up
because there's people chasing it you
know few you know half the number of
people chasing it as there are
you know you got two houses for sale for
every buyer
well all of a sudden prices stabilize
start to go down start to
or at least quit shooting through the
roof so the out of control
upward inflation so we're probably going
to see some actual inflation out of this
which we've not seen in two decades
but in 1982 or yeah in
1980s under carter the uh interest rates
on housing
was eighteen percent seventeen percent i
was in in college so
on real estate so guess what happened
nobody's buying houses
because your interest rate on a house is
like a credit card that's insane yeah
and so nobody's buying houses they're
all on the sideline going i can't buy a
house with these interest rates yep
and so everybody that would have bought
a house that year starts stacking up
and you get pent-up demand water behind
the dam it's getting really
spill over the dam and so when rates
came down
from 18 to 14.
i was selling real estate at 22 years
old
and rates were 14 and there were cars
lined up around the block in the new
subdivision
it was like just that 4 i mean like yeah
but but but it was three
four years of nobody buying a house and
the floodgates broke loose 14 was enough
to get them out of their house yeah and
it was like kovad they lined up around
the dadgum block buying these houses
and guess what prices went up interest
rates continued to go on down
yeah of course over the years after that
we saw 12 and then we saw 10 and
i was on the radio by then and i'm like
oh you'll never see single digit
interest rates again ever in mortgages
well obviously i was an idiot and didn't
know what i was talking about because
we've had single digit interest rates
and now we've had what we've had for
a decade we've had two or three percent
i was going to say it's like went down
last year yeah you know you watch these
interests that's the other thing you
watch these interest rates go up with
inflation yeah
it'll shut this housing market down i
was going to say how yeah the
correlation between inflation and the
interest if you go from three to six
this housing market will freeze like a
deer in the headlights it'll just stop
people just stop buying they'll just
back up and wait
and uh that's you're gonna see some of
that back and forth
now it's going to be a little rocky a
little volatile but it won't this
feeding frenzy that you've got right
this second is not going to continue
yeah
but you do not want to be buying a house
or selling a house right now without a
pro in your corner
oh sure this is not this is not amateur
hour right here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
really not amateur
just a bizarre this is how you can
overpay for something or
or you know not get them you could you
could be off a hundred grand on what you
could have got
with an agent that knew how to
manipulate the whole process yeah
because it's basically a freaking
auction in some of these cities on some
of these properties
that was one of ours in our neighborhood
the builder
did an auction he was like highest price
and people were like
i mean it was a good it was put them out
in the front yard crazy i was like
what is happening right now yeah yeah
well that but that's that it's
i don't know if it's just now yeah but
it's an emotional frenzy well that's it
too buying a home
if you just back up and go right now i'm
just gonna chill and watch all these
crazy people finish
and when they finish then i'm to walk
back in there because you can't get a
deal
in most markets let's add let's add one
more variable to it
all the people leaving california
because they're sick of it they're done
they're done with crazy land all the
people leaving new york
because they're done with crazy land and
they're they're coming out of there like
oh they're right you can't chicago
here's another short here's another
shortage
u-hauls u-haul's leaving california you
can't find one
you can't find them to rent one you mean
you really you can't rent one in new
york
because they're leaving they're all
leaving and they're not coming back
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
as we take your questions about your
life and your money kendra is in houston
texas
hey kendra how are you good how about
yourself
better than i deserve what's up
um i have a quick question for you um
you and rachel um
my husband and i are had just finished
baby step 3b
um and we're closing on our first home
yeah
i know very exciting we've worked really
following your principles we've worked a
really long time so we're very excited
good for you um but i have a good
question in regards to that
so our lender contacted us this morning
saying that we qualified for a property
inspection waiver or essentially an
appraisal waiver
um and where they would still like we
don't need an appraiser to come
praise her to come out and appraise the
thing they would give us the loan
is that something we should do or i'm
just i just need a little bit of wisdom
on that
okay uh how much are you putting down
uh we're putting down um 77 000.
okay and what's the price range home it
is
300. okay
i have not run into this is it are you
getting a conventional loan
we are we're getting the convention
alone and we just locked our rate in
yesterday
okay i think i'm learning something
right now i've never heard of them
waving an appraisal so it's okay that
they are it's just unusual
in the past it was unheard of so it may
have to do with the hot market it may
have to do with the down payment size so
they feel safe
because you're putting a big chunk down
you know that kind of thing so
uh here's the thing the appraisal is an
opinion
of value how comfortable
are you that you're not dramatically
overpaying
i would feel pretty comfortable we
didn't go um that
we paid basically offered at this price
which obviously we've done the comp etc
with our
um realtor oh you did cops okay okay so
you looked at cars
they pulled everything and you you com
you did comparable analysis
using the comparable sales in the area
and that that gave you an indication
that the price is accurate
yes that's correct that's what an
appraisal is
okay an appraisal a standard residential
appraisal form
has three comps on it and they adjust
for the differences in square footage
and
and attributes and uh amenities and so
forth
and so if you've got a four bedroom
versus a three bedroom or a three-car
garage versus a two-car garage or
whatever they adjust for that
and then they adjust 3 500 square feet
to 3700 square feet
and after the adjusted price that that
other house that sold adjusted to look
like yours equals
x the other one equals y the other one
equals z and the average of those three
is
is how a residential appraisal is done
so you've already done one
yeah i guess i guess we kind of
essentially have yeah so
the only reason you would need one is if
you were unsure about the price and i'm
not unsure about it after listening to
you
okay okay i just didn't want to do
anything i mean because i didn't even
know that was an option until we get
somebody i didn't either
i just i i've never heard of yeah so i'm
learning something with you right here
but
you see my point the only reason you
would buy an appraisal is to protect you
and you're okay
okay okay i just didn't know if like us
doing kind of our own and with our
realtor
if anything would be different it's
gonna be it might it might be a
tiny bit off but it's not i mean the the
where your realtor pulled the comps from
is where the residential appraisal
appraiser is gonna pull the comps from
so very likely would be the exact same
comps or
you know if you pull five three of those
will be on that form probably
okay cool if they're if they're close in
geographic proximity
and close in date of sale and fairly
close
in attributes it's not good to compare a
3 500 square
foot house with a 7 000 square foot
house okay it's not good to compare one
that sold last year at this time
last month and it's and within five or
ten percent of square footage and five
or ten percent of the same attributes
you mean you've got a very good comp
then right you see what i'm doing
right yeah i do yeah that's how it's
done so you're i i think you're very
safe
okay i'm just i find out i'm very risk
adverse when it comes time to
purchasing a home
about everything but let me tell you
what does away with risk is knowledge
okay and that's what you're doing it's
what you're doing you're gathering
knowledge here
and so you're not trusting me i hope i'm
trying to get you to say
you understand this and you know what
your value is and so you're safe
yeah but when you're in i mean it's your
first home control
so yeah you mean you're one of the
largest purchase you'll probably ever
make in your lifetime and so you're
thinking
oh gosh i want to do it right so i get
that
yeah and and in times past mortgage
companies always required an appraisal
to protect them to not make a loan
that's too big
on a house that's not worth what the
loan is or something
and they you know in times past that's
what the appraisal was always for
it was required by them for
them but you got the benefit of the
actual safety
extra safety coverage but the
methodology for the appraisal and the
comparative market analysis is identical
and so you know your your real estate
agent can do an appraisal
that is the same thing your appraiser
would do if they're
if they're a decent real estate agent
ryan is with us ryan's in chicago hey
ryan how are you
i'm doing well how about you dave better
than i deserve what's up
hey dave i'm calling in i recently found
you on youtube
like a lot of callers i've been
listening to you getting a lot of
knowledge
now trying to put things in practice i
recently went through a divorce
that was not my choice i'm sorry and as
worse yeah thank you for your
condolences there
um and as everything kind of the dust
settled uh i'm kind of taking
i'm on baby step two i only have one
debt
uh i kind of foolish i bought a european
luxury
vehicle for about fifty thousand i owe
about twenty thousand on it
and after all of the community assets
have been divided up i ended up with
about twenty five thousand
in precious metals about a hundred and
twenty thousand
in cash and some toys boy toys like a
you know motorcycle
about fifteen thousand and some other
items so i had one outstanding debt for
twenty thousand dollars on a vehicle
but i kind of feel stuck in stasis uh
i'm kind of in a hybrid step
i'm i just started investing ten percent
with my company matching
six percent of uh pre-tax
into the 401k and then uh with the
assets on hand i'm kind of
i i've lost some money in cryptocurrency
i've lost some money in the stock market
we had to sell our home
because of the divorce and so now as i'm
taking stock at you know a little over
40 years old
what do i want to do with the cash on
hand it's just fitting
and i kind of find myself frozen a
little bit not really knowing
what to do with it i don't have a lot of
faith in what the stock market is going
to do so i thought
well hey first time caller short time
listener
would love to get your advice okay well
ryan i'll i'll speak up in
part of this so a couple of things i
mean you have yeah 125
000 in cash and so that will cover
the car debt that you have so i would do
that
asap i would take the remaining
probably hundred thousand dollars and
figure out how much
your expenses are per month and set some
of that aside so we always talk about
getting a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
and you would not put this in the market
you would put it in a you know a high
yield savings account or a money market
account
that fully funded emergency fund and
then from there
bump up that 10 percent that you're
investing to 15
and and i would say with the medals i
mean
commodities are just a tough thing to to
have money in so
i don't know what you would say dave but
i mean i would i would sell those and
not have
have that around me 25 000 and that's a
lot and if you
that'd pay off the car that one
even though the the five-year
performance of silver and gold
has been very favorable
for those who have held it you would
still go ahead and sell that in terms of
50-year uh performance of silver and
gold
absolutely sucks okay the long track
record
i mean and so i don't i don't buy stuff
i don't buy entire investment classes
based on their five-year returns it's a
high risk
play you can do it if you want to do it
but i don't have any money in precious
metals i don't even mean bitcoin
uh bitcoin's made a bunch of money this
year
a lot of money but i don't do short term
plays i do long term plays i'm the
tortoise and every time i read the book
he wins
so yeah i'm cashing the medals out
paying off the car what rachel said
finish your emergency fund
just speed fast go fast forward right
through those right through those baby
steps dude
hold on i'll send you a copy of the
total money makeover since you're a new
listener and it'll show you the baby
steps
in detail and if you'll just follow them
you'll be a millionaire in no time
i'm sorry for your hurt your broken
heart's part of this decision-making
paradigm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality number
one best-selling author my daughter is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five carol
is with us in fort wayne indiana hi
carol how are you
i am fine thank you very much sure
what's up my husband and i
have been blessed that we are already in
step
seven yay that the house has paid off
we're in our early 60s and i'm
wondering how do we now relax and enjoy
that we're in this position
congratulations thank you we are still
nervous to
spend money yeah cautious
well you had a lot of years of using
that muscle
yes and uh so how much money do you have
what's the nest egg
we have around a million dollars in
assets
good for you oh in assets okay so how
much of that is the house
probably 250 275. okay
so seven eight hundred grand in your
retirement or in mutual funds or
whatever then right
yes okay good for you good for you yeah
this is something carol i feel like we
we hear a lot from you know whether it's
baby step seven or
even baby step four five and six after
people have done their emergency fund
and gotten out of debt
it's like they emotionally haven't
caught up to where they are and you guys
are you guys retired
not yet my husband will retire probably
in two
three years okay okay yeah so i think
that this is
it's a very normal place to be in that
question and kind of that
that uh hesitancy to just enjoy and so
for me
i know numbers and facts
help me a lot and so it's not like this
idea you're just gonna go crazy and
spend whatever you want
because you guys are at this point you
know you're gonna still have a budget
you're still gonna live on it
you're going to be able to increase your
lifestyle you know percentage points and
so you guys can do that run out the
numbers
and that's when you can get comfortable
when you say okay yeah we can do this
like we
and when you actually have the numbers
in front of you and it's not just this
idea in my head in your head
that's going to help settle some of that
emotion
yeah right and you suggest doing that
with a financial advisor or running it
on our own
both probably but but uh you've got to
get them
into you have to get the numbers into
your heart to relax
um and so what i do uh what sharon and i
often do is because
you know we're in a financial place that
our emotions
may never catch up to uh having gone
bankrupt and then having
struggled and fought and been frugal for
so many years and then
you live like no one else then later
when it's time to live like no one else
then it's hard to relax and do it so the
rule we kind of use is the rule we kind
of use
is whatever the thing is that's we're
thinking about doing and we go are we
crazy
you know we ask ourselves okay if we
take that much money
let's just make up a number let's say
you were gonna go buy a 20
000 something that feels
luxurious to you it feels like you might
be out of control it feels a little
crazy okay
you know what i'm talking about i mean
you're going on a cruise or you're
buying a car or you're buying
i don't know i don't care what it is a
twenty thousand dollar thingy
okay then the quite the way the way we
visualize it is we say all right let's
put twenty thousand dollars cash in the
middle of the kitchen table and burn it
did our life change
and in your case the answer would be no
other than you almost threw up when i
said it but i mean
but you know but mathematically you got
a million dollars
house and and you know and and mutual
funds and retirement and so if you just
took 20 000 and just completely
screwed up and it just disappeared it
evaporated
that's 0.002 percent
it doesn't matter it's like most people
buying a biscuit
that sounds hard to get in your mind
wrapped around i know but
but mathematically mathematically and
logically what i'm saying is correct
isn't it yes it is emotionally it's hard
to accept
and that's the difference and so we just
have to ask ourselves and and we do this
in two areas
consumption and generosity
yes because we uh one of our great
motivators is generosity
and so you can get out of control with
that
and have given everything away and be
eating you know be on the bread line
or whatever you know and so we ask
ourselves if we make this gift
that feels like it is the law i mean
it's more than we made
some years you know but now if we make
this gift i mean
you probably had a year like i did where
you didn't make twenty thousand didn't
you
you did yeah and so if i give a 20 000
gift you give a 20 000
gift away for us that's more than we
made in a whole year
back in the day so it's in our emotions
it feels like
wow but
you're not even gonna know it's gone
because it's 20 000 out of a million
that's true well we keep saying to
ourselves we can't take it with us
well that's true yeah yeah i mean you
know i just read uh my buddy andy anders
just did a post he said you know you put
you can own hotels and boardwalk or you
can rent on baltic but at the end of the
story
you no matter which one you do the the
all the pieces in the board game goes
back in the box
so so here's what i want you to i want
you to work on generosity and i want you
to work
on that exercise to say
all right let's buy something let's look
at something we've always wanted in
quotes
dot dot that when i get there someday
i'm gonna do dot dot dot i'm gonna
travel to that place i'm gonna buy that
thing
whatever that is okay and i want you to
put that amount of money in the middle
of the table and both of you talk about
it and process the
intellectual understanding that it
doesn't matter because it's a small
enough percentage of your world
that it's like most people buying a
biscuit
we'll do that so like i've got a friend
that i went uh it was just
he and i were talking about this same
thing a few years ago i went to an event
with him
and he's a billionaire he has a thousand
million not one million he has a
thousand million
that's a lot and he had just
bought 125 000 car and it was the first
new car he had ever bought
and it's a really nice mercedes 125 000
and he was feeling a little bit guilty
like maybe he should have given that
money
or and he got hate mail somebody sent
him hate mail cause he shouldn't
as a christian he shouldn't have spent
that much money on a car and he's
feeling a little bit guilty about that
and on the other hand too he was he's
like
i don't know if this was wise or not
he's just like a little kid
he's a billionaire where he's coming
from yeah i know
but he's a billionaire and buying a
hundred thousand dollars i mean when you
have a thousand million and you spend a
hundred thousand i mean it's like it's
like somebody's dropping a dollar bill
out their window of the car
it doesn't show up mathematically and
and by the way it's none of your
business what he drives you get to do
your own thing all of you out there
you don't get to pass judgment on other
people although you think because of
social media it's your freaking job
but you know so carol i want you to
increase your generosity
to the level that it makes you touch
this same nerve
and i want you to increase your spending
on a single
luxury item that makes you touch this
nerve
and that'll cause you to be able to do
tooth to relax
so we increase our giving we increase
our spending
but only if we do it wrong or
when the money is just gone it it didn't
change our life
yeah in that and it's a great exercise
to think about it because
because again the emotions have not
caught up with the math and so you're
having to get
pushed through it but once you start to
do this carol over the next
you know year or two you'll get used to
doing it yes
you're not you're never going to be a
rash
out of control spender you will you will
not do that
you just can't it's not possible for you
to do it
the number of people that i've seen that
think like you think that
lose everything because they overspend
are zero
they're just not people just don't make
that trip
you will never go over to the land of
stupid you just
you you you'll be so far away from it
that it's just not in the cards for you
so you're safe you're safe you're gonna
be okay but what i want you to do is
just learn to enjoy some of the money
and learn to be generous with some of
the money at a level that it really
doesn't affect your life
but it really increases your enjoyment
for all the years of hard work and
saving
yeah i was going to say you guys have
sacrificed you've earned saying carol
have some fun live like no one else and
now you get to live and give
like no one else and that's the whole
thing and there's nothing wrong with
that morally spiritually
there's nothing wrong with that
financially you are great you're amazing
i'm so proud of you
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
the ramsay show.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice rachel
cruz ramsey personality and best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
and uh big day today rachel is launching
a new
version of the rachel cruz
wallet a new color a new color
yes it's not a version that's right no
but it is is
great though uh so yes for a limited
time
we have a metallic blush
wallet ladies and so in the wallet there
are 10 card slots so debit cards gift
cards membership cards all of that is in
there
and then five or four sewn in
envelopes so if you're using the
envelope system it's in there and even
you know we talk about the cash how
important it is but those of you on baby
steps four five and six you know
it gets to a point that you've been
budging for a while and cash isn't
always
the the only way to go about it and so i
know for me it's always a place just to
put
receipts or you have stuff you just
stick in it's kind of like when i think
of my
my bags my favorite organizer my purses
the bigger the better because i just
throw everything in
and so even if you don't use cash this
is still a great
option so it is here the rachel cruz
blush wallet for a limited time you go
to ramsey solutions.com
um again we have a limited quantity
and then there will be no more and there
will be no more of the blush i know it's
so pretty though
so mother's day if you need a gift for
mother's day this is a great a great
option but it's
it's oh it might be my it's my favorite
color for sure
yeah real leather made in india by yes
join we partnered with join
and they're an incredible organization
there they make authentic leather goods
so this is
real leather and they take people
off the streets or in terrible
situations and
employ them they give them the
opportunity to completely change their
family trees so while you buy this
wallet you're
changing your family tree by committing
to do something with your money that
maybe you've never done before
like being on a budget and using cash
but also
you are helping people change their
family trees on the other side of the
world completely
so join is an incredible an incredible
organization and
they make an incredible product like
it's you know i mean like it's so
really hard i mean it's so good you guys
it's so so great so
there's that again roomysolutions.com
store and it'll put you right there on
the metallic blush you have the other
two colors we have plenty of the other
two colors
yes black and camel are the other two
original wallets that came out
yes so they will be there but again
limited edition for mother's day
the metallic rose gold kate is in kansas
city to start off this hour hey kate
what's up
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call
my mother-in-law is 60 and i'm trying to
help her with her finances she has
36 000 in retirement and if she was to
start your baby step she'd be
on baby step 2 and she has 20 000 in
student loan debt
so with her budget she only has like a
500
she could put towards the debt which
means it's gonna take her over three
years to pay off the debt and then
additional six months to get the
emergency fund in place so
she would only be around age 64 to start
actually
putting money into retirement and she
says she wants to retire
by like 66. so um
because of all that she doesn't really
want to put anything towards debt right
now
and just invest in retirement and i
know you never change the order of your
baby steps
so i know that's what i would want or i
want to recommend
um and i have but she just doesn't see
it
that way and so i'm hoping you can help
me
like word it in a way that it shows that
that's the best way
and then also just your thoughts on her
retiring at 66 i don't know
if that's the best thing to do with her
financial situation
this is a hard one because emotionally
where she's at though
is she's freaking out because she thinks
i have 36 thousand dollars in retirement
and that's it and i want to retire at 66
and
all my money is going to go to my
retirement i mean that's your knee-jerk
reaction
but what you have to realize and what
she needs to realize is
even having a twenty thousand dollar
student loan debt
um is risk not having other cash in the
bank for an emergency fund
is risk as well and so getting to a
point where she can clean up all of that
she's able to clean up the debt and have
that cash set aside it's going to put
her
in such a better place but the urgency
is going to have to kick in because
money flows
two ways i mean money flows in money
flows out and like you said flowing out
she's got about 500 in the budget if
you've done a really tight budget
and then you're going to she's gonna
have to figure out what to do between
now and then to bring in some extra
income to get the student loan paid off
even faster
what does she make uh she makes about
three thousand months
doing what uh she makes dentures
so she works 40 hours yeah
okay um she's not gonna like this either
but she needs another job yeah and
another job and another job
like six jobs because
let me tell you what she has right now a
fantasy
none of this is going to happen with
what you just described
if she gets rid of this debt before
retirement on the budget you're talking
about i'll be shocked
yeah and because she's not serious about
it because she doesn't have any hope
because she can't see the numbers
getting there and um
you know with five hundred dollars a
month is six thousand dollars a year
that's eighteen
thousand dollars in three years that is
not going to make her be able to retire
it's a fantasy so she needs some income
yeah um and uh so is she was
your father-in-law was it a divorce that
he passed away
a divorce how long ago oh
20 years and she's still mad married
she was remarried again and then she
that didn't work out and they got
divorced a couple years ago
and she actually they declared
bankruptcy from that
so that wiped out any debt she had
before that except the student loan
because student loans aren't
bankruptable well
that this was actually a new loan for
additional schooling for
dental work um 20 000 to make 36
yeah wow okay
um well her problem is that that
in order for any of these things to
occur she's going to have to increase
her income so she's going to be working
a lot of hours
she can actually end up with 100 to 200
000
in her nest egg and be debt free by 66
or 67
but not on 40 hours a week making 36
000.
okay we have to she's going to add some
hours to her life
i know she's tired i know she doesn't
want to do it but i don't want to retire
and have to eat alpo
either so uh
i don't know what the extra job is that
makes her a bunch of money
making and working another 40 hours a
week for the next two years
but that'll solve a lot of these
problems because she can create another
three thousand dollars a month
bad news is her income sucks good news
is it's easy to double
is she receptive kate did she listen to
you
um i mean she was willing to meet with
me um
so uh that was positive what about her
son is she willing to meet with him
um i think so yeah i think he needs to
step on mom and say mom
you're gonna have to up the game here
baby uh because
if she's not listening to you she needs
to listen to somebody because
you know it's not a it's not a baby
steps out of order problem it's an
income problem
that's the math breakdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
where we talk about your life your money
and your life it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five here at ramsey
solutions
we wanna transform so many lives
that the toxic culture is disrupted
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan
where people pay cash for their cars
where they know how to operate in their
marriage and raise their kids
imagine a world where they know how to
get the job that they love and hire the
people
that they want on their team and be high
quality world-class leaders
imagine being part of an organization
that caused
that level of disruption to our toxic
culture
that's the work we do here and that's
why we have a thousand folks on our team
working together we create digital
products we create
services we create shows
books any way we can get to you folks
and help you
if you want to join on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt for software
engineers with expertise in ruby on
rails
java c-sharp front-end technologies
if you're a ux designer seo content
marketing specialist
we'd love to talk to you we're hiring
about 300 people this year
and also sales positions also positions
of all kinds hr positions
we've got tons of them if you want to
find out more about what's happening at
ramsey
and the available jobs text work that
matters to 33789 text
work that matters to 33
7 89 and you can find out
about all of the open opportunities that
are here carter is with us in
billings montana hi carter welcome to
the ramsay show
hello how are you better than i deserve
what's up
i got a funny question so we probably
have too much money wrapped up in their
cars but they're paid off
um and we have very little debt maybe
oh 24 000 in the camper and
and that's about it um and then we have
a mortgage
you know no second no nothing and we own
some real estate on the side
free and clear just raw land uh i feel
kind of silly having this much money
wrapped up in cars
how much do you have wrapped up in cars
well probably between two of them i
could sell them for probably 95 000 come
away with 95 000
in cash what's your household income 200
okay it's not it's not completely out of
line
it does i can understand how it feels
silly but the rule of thumb we use
is that you shouldn't own things with
car with with motors and wheels
or wheels or motors that totaled up
equals more than half your annual income
camper camper puts you over yes it does
and so and it has debt so the thing i
would sell the thing i would sell is the
camper
okay what do you think carter yeah it's
not you don't like that i'm just
thinking
let's take it two years from now and the
cars depreciate then it drops below our
oh you know the the annual income i'm
just i felt kind of silly that we paid
cash for that stuff
and you know we could have put it
towards i don't know what else we put it
towards but
i wouldn't have bought it if i didn't
pay cash for it right
so i don't feel silly if you're paying
cash for it i feel silly for buying it
maybe
yeah but um i mean you're right up at
the top you did but you got a lot tied
up and things going the wrong direction
yeah but you got a great income and you
can offset that but you do need to
it sounds like you've been sloppy and
you need to tighten up your decision
making and tighten up your plan right
correct that's all it is i mean you
don't have anything here that's
devastating you're not going bankrupt
you're not
you know you're not way over in the
stupid zone where i got to go what you
know but
um it's not that but it's just it's
close
you know and that's why that's why
you're feeling the pinch i mean
because the bottom line is when you've
got more than half your annual income
tied up and things that are going down
in value it's hard to become wealthy
sure it's a it's a simple principle and
that's
that's what it comes down to so how long
have you made 200
um several years decade okay
what are the cars uh it's uh
one ton ram pickup to uh 2019 and then a
toyota highlander
okay 2016. yeah
okay yeah i would say car i mean the
cars aren't the problem at this point i
mean
like you said they're pretty they're
paid for all of it and so i get how it
feels kind of
and i'm pretty sure we can pay the
camper off pretty damn darn excuse me
darn easy this year yeah yeah knock it
out knock the camper out if you want to
hold on that's fine
but and then just draw a line in the
sand and go we're not going to be back
up here again
right and so what happened was the i can
tell you which car was purchased last
obviously based on the year but also
based on just the how the story's going
down you bought this big but expensive
truck
over the top killer massively wonderful
truck
and you just completely boy impulsed on
it and you're feeling regret
well it's middle of the line and my old
truck was 22 years old and it's been
paid off forever so
yeah you could say that yeah and so i
mean you could have
you you're wishing you had bought a
truck about between the two
correct and not over the top that's you
got that taste of regret on the back of
your tongue
and that's all it is and i i've i've had
that taste that's how i know what it
tastes like so um i get it i understand
so just the thing is uh
do a little uh autopsy on the whole
situation and go okay what do i never
want to do again as a result of this
story
spend that much money well what did i do
wrong that i wished i hadn't done
okay and um so
you know that that's what i ask myself
when i do you know i've done a lot of
stupid stuff my goal is to not do the
same
stupid thing because i figure out what
it is and just put that
okay i got that one behind me i don't
have to do that one again because i've
already done that one
there will be another one but i don't
have to do that one and if you
if you have a big enough pile of stupid
things that you never do again people
call you wise like you know how to
navigate this
you know your way through this it's
cause i know what stupid looks like and
lots of it but the problem is when you
do the same thing over and over and over
again
right and you just keep going back to
the same dumb thing and then that's the
definition of insanity
uh doing the same thing over and over
again expecting different results so i i
don't i think the
emotion of this is what's more important
than the actual math yeah i mean if you
tighten up the budget you pay off the
camper all of it you're going to look up
in 12 months carter and
probably feel a completely different set
of emotions right now than that
little feeling you're feeling yeah and
truthfully if you say
okay these two parts of the decision
were the bad parts i will never do those
two things again
it's easier to put all of this behind
you and move on and just
leave the trucks and the cars in place
and get you know get on with it don't
right
just don't do that again you know that
kind of thing
yeah because you you you didn't go over
well you did with the camper you did you
did go over
but um you know so you but there's
nothing here that's
requiring it to all be undone
it doesn't do any good could sell the
camper though still could
uh walter's with us in vermont hey
walter what's up
thank you so much for taking my call my
wife and i have an opportunity to
refinance our mortgage
our mortgage company has because the
interest rates have gone down
uh significantly since we originally got
the mortgage just a couple of years ago
when we bought the house they've
actually given us what's your current
right
current rate is 3.375 what are they
offering you drop it down
to 2.875
it's not a huge drop um it would save us
37 dollars per month the only thing is
they cannot
they kick in what's your loan balance
loan balance is 154 000.
okay you're gonna save a half a percent
a year
on a hundred and fifty four thousand
you'll save 750 a year
what's the closing cost uh no closing
costs because they're gonna
they're gonna nothing out of pocket at
all
nothing out of pocket at all the only
thing they do though because it's an fha
loan
oh it's a streamline they're talking
about 900
onto the loan amount for insurance okay
but nothing out of pocket
per year no no
well it would take 254 and add on 900
to it no are you adding 900 per year
or one time no just one time well then
it takes you a little over a year to
break even because you're saving 750
750 a year on a half a percent
savings and takes you a little over a
year to break even if you're gonna stay
in the house three or four years it's
gonna make a little bit of sense
this is not a life-changing thing it's
750
a year it's probably not worth screwing
with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five
five two two five suzanne is with us in
utica new york hi suzanne how are you
oh i'm okay i have a problem with
i sold some stocks and
my advisor had told me that they would
not be taxed
or counted as income and when i did a
my income tax online which i didn't push
the button yet to send it but um
i it's showing that now i owe the
federal over a thousand
and the state over a thousand
and i just wondered what what did i do
wrong besides this and
listen to maybe some bad advice maybe or
maybe the online software sucks
okay that's possible you may be getting
a wrong result from the online software
what are you using turbotax
no it was the irs oh god
okay yeah that's bad all right so
uh what did you sell how much did you
sell
um yeah i sold
forty thirty five thousand dollars
worth okay and d do you know what your
basis was
in that does that mean how much i
paid how much you paid for that stock
that sold for thirty five
yeah but the um the agency that holds my
stuff
doesn't have that information they don't
no why what happened well let's see
when i got to stock it was purchased
through an employer and i
can't remember if if i purchased it
through payroll and they matched some
i think that's the way it went and then
when i met this advisor
we put the stocks into a company
that she was advising me to do and
you put you you did you sell the stocks
for the old stocks i got certificates
i got certificates and then you move
this how did you move certificates into
something else
i don't remember okay um i mean i've got
all the paperwork
so how did you what did you put in this
attack software that calculated that you
owed a thousand you'd have to have your
basis to do the calculation
nope how much i sold no you
you sold it for 35 000 what you paid for
it
the difference in what the difference in
what you paid for it and what you sold
it for is your gain
and that's what you're taxed on okay so
they
cast me on the 35 000 because i didn't
have a cost basis
yeah i'll see that's not right you do
you do have a cost basis of some kind
and it should not be
okay your tax would be more than a
thousand dollars on 35 000
okay okay so you have a mess so and i
can't i can't untangle this barrel of
fish hooks on the radio but what i'm
going to do is this how old are you
i have some homework i'm 67
67 okay yeah and it's just you
yes you're widowed or what i'm widowed
okay we're going to take care of you we
take care of widows
so i'm going to pay for out one of our
people that we recommend
for tax advice a tax professional
in the new york area to take care of you
free
thank you because the irs software sucks
and you have a messed up
lack of information and you're getting
ready to get yourself
into a mess that you don't need to get
into
you probably don't owe a lot of taxes
but you've got to have to have some help
scratching through
and getting your proper information
together to prove that
and we'll help you do that i'll get you
with one of our tax elps one of the tax
professionals that we recommend
they will take care of you as a gift
from us kelly will take care of that i'm
gonna put you on hold and she's gonna
pick up
and do that so rachel usually when you
sell stock
the if you had a broker
you know that you bought it through that
company has the records
sure of what you paid for it your basis
and the difference in what you pay for
it and what you sell it for
is taxable and if it's been held longer
than a year it's taxable 15
unless you make over 400 thousand
dollars so uh
in her case she'll be taxed at 15 on the
gain
and so she if she if they're showing her
gain is 35 000
the thousand dollars in taxes is not
right it's a lot more than that right
right
yeah uh but uh so we've got to get the
actual basis figured out
and you may have to go back to the
former employer or you may have to file
some kind of estimated
that's what it's going to say how do you
even well there's a the irs has a has a
process for filing an estimated basis
when you
you know i mean it has to be based on
logic you can't just make it up i mean
right you have to make a series of
assumptions and they'll they'll
a tax advisor can walk you through that
so um
and but somebody should have a basis
somewhere on that
and and poor suzanne sitting there
dealing with the irs.gov
oh my goodness i will tell you this
there there's
if you have a simple return online is
fine and we have a we have a product
called smart tax
that's like 17 and if you you know if
you're just doing your 1040 easy
and you want to file online it's really
easy to run it on smart tax
and you can get that at
ramseysolutions.com in the store
um or if you have a complicated return
or a situation where you need some help
like that you need a professional in
your corner we have the elps
in each area that we recommend that are
tax professionals that do tax preparing
and they cost more than 17
but you're going to save a lot more
because you you know you've got a small
business or you've got a transaction
like that or
something else going on and you can get
all of that at ramsey solutions
yeah anytime there's those complicated
or more intimidating parts of
money it's always good to bring a
professional in so whether it's real
estate
taxes investing i mean anything that
just feels like
it's a little overwhelming it's a little
complicated you may not even be able to
if you can't explain it to someone else
that means you have to you need to learn
and you need to to grow in knowledge and
part of that sitting down
with a professional and letting them
help you i mean these people i can't
believe it but breathe in and out this
information day and day they love it i
mean
you know these tax professionals this is
what they do and they see every
every every situation they've had
probably suzanne's
um circumstance before in their office i
don't know what to do
you want to bring them on because yeah
like you said it's going to save so much
time and money
jonathan is in raleigh north carolina
hey jonathan what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call
better than hey good how can we help
i was going to answer better than i
deserved but what do i know i just was
wandering along lost here how can i help
so i developed a product that's industry
specific and i was wondering if you
could give me some advice on when to
actually file a patent
like is there a number of units that i
need to sell
or like a dollar amount before i file my
patent to
i guess prove it in the market or take
it to market to be mass producer
licensed or whatever
you can patent a prototype um
the patent space is full of a bunch of
shysters
and so you don't need to pay somebody
big dollars i mean there's things i've
heard people pay 250 000
to get a patent attorney and all this
and you do not need to do that
uh my understanding is and i've had lots
of clients that have done this have
patented
a prototype for usually costs around 10
grand but you've got to work your way
through the process
and you have to have the is it a product
a hard product
yes sir and so i i have a friend who
also has a bunch of trademarks and
patents and he introduced me to
his patent attorney she did a patent
search
through a legit firm and came back that
there's no other product
like this what did she charge you for
that
a thousand dollars that's good what will
she charge you to run the patent
uh 2500 500 of which is for the
draftsmanship
that's that's that's a reasonable deal
yeah maximum of 10 grand out of pocket
but
i've heard lots there's all these things
on the internet where they'll help you
market the product and help you get the
patent and all this stuff and
and they don't do anything what is it
jonathan i'm just curious
it's a um for lack of a better term it's
a it's a tool pouch it
helps us carry tools i'm alive and by
trade and it
yeah yeah i would spend the money with
her to do it it'd be that simple i do
we've got bunches and bunches of
trademarks we don't have any patents
uh but we've trademarked everything
around here like crazy so i spent a lot
of money on that got a lot of knowledge
on copyrights and trademarks
because that's the publishing world and
the uh you know these
all of these images and things that we
own here
are part of it that and urls uh my god
but the uh um
yeah so i i think if you can keep it
down under ten thousand dollars and you
have the cash to do it and you get it
patented
you can do it with a prototype that's
all you gotta do and i would do that
sooner rather than later
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day james 1 17
every good
and perfect gift is from above
coming down from the father of the
heavenly lights
who does not change like shifting
shadows
william james says most people never run
far enough on their first win to find
out if they've got a second oh
anna's with us in phoenix hey anna
what's up
hi how are you better than i deserve how
can we help
hi um so i started listening to you
in july um i was 37 000
in debt um my fiance
he was around 120 130 to the irs
a thousand dollars and um so
i got to the point where now i'm at 19
and we didn't separate but he moved down
to new mexico
to try to figure out he did an
application of
oic yeah to try to see
if they could help them out um most of
it is really interesting
and i just wanted to know like are we
doing like
the right thing i mean i make around 35
to 40 000 a year
so what does he make he he was making 80
000 because he works in the oil field
but it went down so now
was he 10.99 and he just didn't pay
taxes
yeah oh my god has he quit doing that
well he now he found a job where they
take out
taxes so he's trying to find a second
job what does he make now at the new job
no he's trying to find oh he's making 40
to 50.
so he got his pay cut in half but the
oil field dried up or what
yeah it's drying up yeah okay
all right move down there how much did
he pay for this oic
well he has a friend um that she used to
work for the irs so she's kind of
guiding him of
what she recommends for him to do
we're just waiting on a response and
he's gonna start like i said he's he's
been saving up money to be you know
start paying off but
he has a lien on his name for the new
mexico state
so he's trying to pay that off first and
then see what the irs says
okay well i i i'm not going to give you
much hope on the
on the oic okay yeah and
offer and compromise is what that stands
for and that is when the irs
observes that you have no assets and no
income so they're never getting their
money
you basically have to prove that you are
completely broke and don't have an
income
and that's not the case here he has an
income and
uh so i don't have a lot of hope that
they're going to just forgive this or
large chunks of it
and even if they do they're going to
want to lump sum
and so if they instead of 95 000 or 120
000 if they come in and say
oh we'll settle for 20 000. they're
gonna want their 20 000 right then and
he don't have any money
well he's not a one now he they have
them at 140 000
yeah but if they settle if they did an
offering compromise
and settled for twenty thousand dollars
they're going with their twenty thousand
dollars right then it's not a payment
plan
yeah so i'm yeah
i don't i don't want to be a a debbie
downer here but the truth is
very few oics get through
i've probably watched a hundred of them
try and i might have seen 10 go through
okay over the years it's just the the
burden
that they put on you to prove that you
have no money
also means that you have no money to
settle with them
when they do finally take it so it's a
it's a two-edged sword in a sense
it gets you coming and going so irs debt
moves to the front of everything
yeah yeah and so i i think uh
what i if i were him you know i'm going
to work the oic through
but i'm not going to work it through for
two years while it continues to double
and triple
with these with these uh penalties going
up and these interest rates going up you
follow me
yeah so uh i mean give this thing 90 120
days
maybe six months uh and in the meantime
be working like a crazy person and
piling up cash
i want a big old pile of cash i want him
working 100 hours a week
and i want a big old pile of cash like
40 50 000 bucks piled up
yeah that's yeah you didn't sound real
enthusiastic that's your only shot kiddo
yeah i know well that's why he he ended
up living out there he moved out there
so he could figure out that situation
why i fixed my situation
i don't know why you can figure out
something in new mexico you can't figure
out in arizona
i know well he's trying to get his cbl
now um
he's finding ways where you don't have
to go to class and pay that whole amount
and
you know try to get out to get a job
down here but okay let me tell you what
i'm hearing
how old are you i'm 29.
okay i'm going to be your uncle dave for
a minute don't you dare pay a dime of
this until you're married
this is his problem this young man needs
to solve this freaking problem
yeah that's why i told him like i'm not
going to get married he doesn't want to
get married yet because of his situation
but
that's why like it was better for me to
pay off my situation i
was you need to get your mess cleaned up
and you can be his biggest cheerleader
but he needs to go he needs to he needs
to roll up his sleeves go make a whole
bunch of money
do nothing but work like a crazy man and
have a big old pile of money
when this thing blows up and the oic
doesn't go through he can get started on
it
because if he throws 50 grand at it
right quick because he's worked 100
hours a week
um then he's got a good start on it it's
the only way it's going away because the
irs just does not go away
it's just uh they're not bankruptible
they're just going to be there and it's
not going to get anything but worse so
the sooner he
you know reverses the trend on this the
better off he's going to be
and i just hear you caring about this
and being more logical about it than he
is
that always kind of concerns me
sometimes when anna you're the one
calling and he's not
so um and again maybe it's situational
and it's today you were able to pick up
the phone call but i want him to be
more involved than you are in his mess
if that makes sense yeah
that's exactly right trying to be nice
on i feel for you
you're you're really good i feel for you
but but
be aware like you need you're you're set
up here for a problem kiddo be careful
jessica's in las vegas hi jessica
welcome to the ramsay show
hi hi hello i'm
super excited i wanted to call as soon
as we get off our debt
we paid off our debt our 27 thousand
dollars in three months
thank you so much you guys i'm so happy
um such a late you know we're listening
you know shoulders however you sound so
nervous i'm sorry
um my question is we are now on step
three
officially and um
you know it's saving three to six months
and
i was wondering if do we still
have to you know go get gazelle
intensity or
can we now sort of um
okay so relax yeah yeah you're gonna ask
yeah can we just relax
and since now we're on baby step three i
wasn't telling you jessica
um no the gazelle intensity continues
until baby step three is done so the
same intensity you guys used
to pay off all that debt i think you
said three months jessica which is
incredible so congratulations
keep that intensity until that baby step
three is paid off yeah
i'm sorry saves that cash here's the
problem jessica
the you you when you don't have
i i've noticed this my whole life when
i'm broke
is like when i attract emergencies
like emergencies just come find me and
when i'm not broke they stay away they
go to other people's house
and so having the emergency fund is like
emergency repellent it keeps the
mosquitoes away it keeps the emergencies
from coming in and if they do come in
you got the money for them
and so it is vitally important that you
become debt-free other than the house
with great intensity and that you finish
the emergency fund with great intensity
but you're gonna do it very fast
because compared to where you were five
months ago
with twenty seven thousand dollars in
debt and no money once you have
twelve thousand dollars in your
emergency fund and no debt
your life has completely changed and you
have done it
congratulations it's amazing but yeah
you do need to continue to lean in
sounds like you all been very intense
and i congratulate you for that
and it won't take that much more a
little bit more i mean if you think
about if you did 27 that fast how fast
can you do 12.
and that's all it is and so then it's
behind you forever
and you've got murphy repellent in your
pocket rachel good great show yeah
thanks for having me on
james childs our producer kelly daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener i'm dave ramsey we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermzyshow.com